want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you too you have michael jordan
level talent at something so today let's
live your best believe life and learn
the seven best lessons from elon musk
oprah winfrey and other billionaire
entrepreneurs
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with lesson
number one make something useful with
elon musk i don't think everyone needs
to go you know try to solve like some
big
big world-changing problem i mean i
think that
like if
i i really think like
we should just think like are we doing
something that's useful
um to the world like if you're doing
something useful that's great yeah i
just think that like you sort of a
usefulness optimization
is is like that's like a really good
thing
um you know if you if you've done
something that's useful to
your fellow human beings that's you've
done a really good thing um and uh
people should feel
proud of doing that um you know it
doesn't doesn't always have to be
something that's going to change the
world i mean sometimes the world should
just keep going in a particular
direction
help the world um yeah it might be
though it might be going in the right
direction in in
and i mean in a lot of ways the the
world is and we're we are
in great shape
in that if you look at say violent
crimes um
you know
um
per capita in the world it's at a like
all-time low
we're actually quite prosperous
[Music]
and
you know compared to in his history
and
you know i think there's a lot of things
to feel good about in terms of how the
world is today
access to information is incredible i
mean
anyone with like a 100 device could have
has access to
basically all the world's information
which is an incredible thing
and um yeah so i honestly i just think
like the best thing for people to try to
do is say like hey what is something i
can do that would really be
be useful uh to the world and just do
that you know that's great lesson number
two get the lesson from failure with
oprah winfrey nobody's journey is
seamless or smooth we all stumble we all
have setbacks if things go wrong you hit
a dead end as you will
it's just life's way of saying
time to change course
so ask every failure this is what i do
every failure every crisis every
difficult time i say what is this here
to teach me
and as soon as you get the lesson you
get to move on
if you really get the lesson you pass
and you don't have to repeat the class
if you don't get the lesson it shows up
wearing another pair of pants
or skirt
to give you some remedial work and what
i found is that difficulties come when
you don't pay attention to life's
whisper
because life always whispers to you
first first and if you ignore the
whisper sooner or later you'll get a
scream
whatever you resist persists but if you
ask the right question not why is this
happening but what is this here to teach
me
what is this here to teach me it puts
you in the place and space to get the
lesson you need my friend ed cartoli uh
who's written this wonderful book
uh called a new earth
that's all about letting the awareness
of who you are stimulate everything that
you do he puts it like this he says
don't react against a bad situation
merge with that situation instead and
the solution will arise from the
challenge
because surrendering yourself doesn't
mean giving up it means acting with
responsibility
okay
many of you know that as president
hennessey said i started this school
in africa
and
i founded the school where i'm trying to
give south african girls a shot at a
future like yours stanford
and i spent five years making sure that
school would be as beautiful as the
students
i wanted every girl to feel her worth
reflected in her surroundings so i
checked every blueprint
i picked every pillow
i was looking at the grout in between
the bricks i knew every thread count of
the sheets i chose every girl from the
villages from nine provinces and yet
last fall i was faced with a crisis i'd
never anticipated i was told that one of
the dorm matrons was suspected of sexual
abuse
well that was as you can imagine
devastating news
first i cried actually i sobbed for
about a half an hour
and then i said let's get to it that's
all you get is a half an hour you need
to focus on the now
what you need to do now so i contacted a
child trauma specialist i put together a
team of investigators i made sure the
girls had counseling and support and
gail and i got on a plane and flew to
south africa and the whole time i kept
asking that question
what is this here to teach me
and as difficult as that experience has
been
i got a lot of lessons
i understand now the mistakes i made
because i
had been paying attention to all of the
wrong things i built that school from
the outside in
when what really mattered was the inside
out
so it's a lesson that applies to all of
our lives as a whole what matters most
is what's inside what matters most is
the sense of
integrity of quality and beauty i got
that lesson and what i know is is that
the girls came away with something too
they've emerged from this more resilient
and knowing that their voices
have power lesson number three select
creative people with jeff bezos one of
the things about maintain first of all
somewhat about the selection of the
people so if you want to have a creative
culture
um
i when i interview people i ask them to
give me an example of something they've
invented and i always point out it
doesn't have to be something that you
actually took to the patent office but
some of you it could be a a metric that
you invented and and followed carefully
it could be a business process that you
invented but how do you go about what's
your method first you want to select
people who like to invent their way out
of boxes
and
um
don't necessarily immediately go to
either or we can do a or b and and you
know the right question is how can we do
a and b what invention do we need to be
able to do both
so that's a lot about selection of
people and the great thing about
corporate cultures is they're very
self-reinforcing so
um this could i mean it it
somebody who comes to amazon
and doesn't like
pioneering doesn't like exploring
doesn't like going down blind alleys
that oftentimes turn out to be dead ends
they'll leave you know they're
self-selecting and so we have over the
last 18 years
collected a bunch of people who really
enjoy
this kind of pioneering approach
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there lesson number four get what you
want with tillman fertitta you mentioned
people are looking at the wrong things
they're thinking about the price or the
other things what should they be
thinking about if they want to acquire
something whether you're a small
business owner that wants to acquire
something for a hundred grand
or you're you know a billionaire like
yourself trying to require something for
2.2 billion what is the thing they look
for well if it's something that you
really really want and you can afford
and it doesn't really matter
uh you should just go get it okay if
it's why is it for the piece of mind
it's just for the peace of mind and so
you never regret it okay i uh i can go
back 20 25 years ago and i've been asked
this the last few days what is i had a
chance to buy this unbelievable car
collection about 25 years ago that had
great muscle cars right when they were
it was unbelievable and i was really
buying it at a bargain because the
father had died the sun was selling it
didn't give a damn yeah and and and
i lost a deal over a couple hundred
thousand dollars that today if i own
that i would just walk in there and say
this is mine i just love it and and i
learned a lesson and and 25 years later
that's the one deal that comes back and
haunts me because i negotiated a little
bit too hard for something that really
mattered now
now let's look it in a box of a real
business deal you can't get caught up
emotionally there's always another deal
and i walk away from deals all the time
really all the time because there's
there's always another deal but you know
what there's only so many great car
collections there's only one nba team in
your own hometown okay and so there's
certain things you don't worry about and
that's where you have to be smart and
say there's always another
casino to buy or another restaurant
company to buy but but but keep keep it
right know what's in the box and know
it's out of the box lesson number five
go for it with mark cuban my dad did
upholstery on cars my mom um
did whatever odd jobs um
but my dad was always like if you want
something you have to earn it and to his
credit he never said no you can't do
that so whether it was selling garbage
bags baseball cards stamps whatever it
was he never held me back and so i think
that was as important as anything and
you know sometimes being young and
trying things you're so naive and you
don't know any better all you do is
learn and if you fail it doesn't matter
and so whether i was 9 10 12 16 21
the failures were irrelevant and you
know whether you're you know 9 12 16 21
22 24 you know i'm sleeping on the couch
you know i have a car with a hole in the
floorboard you know i'm i'm living like
a bum and like a student and so what did
i have to lose and so i think that
influenced me as much as anything so
you know my dad was like go for it you
know don't why not what have you got to
lose you know you have to sleep on a
different couch last number six embrace
hate with grant cardone handling kind of
criticism and people saying don't do
that or you can't do that because you
know
on any kind of success journey you do
get a lot of that what how did you kind
of handle that
yeah you know in the beginning you're
not ready for i was not ready for the
amount of
um
criticism you know first you're going to
be ignored
in the beginning you're just going to be
ignored nobody's going to even pay
attention to you you could be jesus you
could walk on water and they're going to
ignore you nobody will even see hey did
you see that did you take a selfie did
you get it on instagram if you didn't it
didn't happen so it doesn't matter like
you could literally save the world and
if nobody saw it they're going to ignore
you in the beginning then they're going
to reject you
third thing they're going to do is
they're going to criticize you make fun
of you
but if you stay with it they're going to
adopt it okay i mean brilliant people
are adopted at the end if they just stay
with the hate along the way is part of
the game for you to get past being
ignored and then rejected you will be
hated on
and once you start accumulating enough
success
uh we we were uh i told my team over
here we got 155 employees i'm like guys
look
you have to be ready
it's coming the criticism
the stuff online don't even look at it
it's all garbage
and if it affects you negatively
it's not about what they're saying it's
about what it does to you personally
i just know it's part of the game now in
the beginning i wasn't ready for it now
i understand oh my success is dependent
upon the hate and the criticism and the
rejection
you got to have it it's part of the it's
part of the recipe of success
unfortunately
because people that quit are going to
hate you for not quitting
they're actually not talking about you
they're talking about themselves
and they're like he's wrong for having a
damn plane
because they quit on their play
everybody can have a plane
the crazy is everybody can have
everything they want because there's
enough to go around for everybody
so
uh for every guy that doesn't have what
he wants there's somebody on this planet
that has the oceanfront house
that goes on as many trips as they want
some guy that's got the 200 foot yacht
some guy
that funded a hospital somewhere and put
his name on it
and and
you know it's just crazy that
the hate always comes from the same
place
a quitter
haters actually own haters they're
quitters and lesson number seven the
last one before some very special bonus
clips is keep innovating with vinod
khosla most of the time when you start
something you want to do something
meaningful
and
get started
and maybe smaller
but you want to keep innovating building
on it one step at a time
and hopefully it becomes much larger
you know amazon started with just books
now it's everything
if you look at twitter or facebook when
they started they were relatively small
things
mokshaka was trying to connect
everybody on the harvard campus
not seven billion people on the planet
but he kept expanding his vision so
very often when you start with an
innovative idea you don't know how big
it is
in fact most of most of the really
innovative ideas have been very hard to
predict what's a large opportunity or a
small opportunity
most people thought
airbnb would this be this very small
nichey little opportunity that a few
people would rent out their rooms and
it'd be a nice little business
now it's huge
people thought uber would be this limo
service business it's now bigger than
all limos all taxis and maybe replacing
personal transportation
so it's not possible to always predict
everything and where things may go
but just because you can't predict where
things may go
doesn't mean
you shouldn't try
or you shouldn't start once you start
and you stay creative and innovative and
keep trying new things
uh things expand
at what point was it where you guys said
huh you know what we might be on to
something here with these paul mitchells
you know shampoo and conditioners which
you guys came to be known for what was
the point where you guys said hmm like
let's do this like what was the well we
were planning to do it because i knew
the business i was in marketing sales
and structure and had connections with
uh product development
and i didn't do hair
paul was a great hairdresser one of the
best in the world
very advanced in what he did however he
didn't do business it was the perfect
combination these two guys together
we're just the best of friends and we
knew we could do it uh obviously we
started out with nothing we made the
decision let's just let's just make this
happen and as you will see in your
guests we'll see when they look at good
fortune the movie and it's on itunes
it's on amazon all those when they look
at it it's a whole story of starting in
america with nothing a couple times and
making things happen because of what you
believe in but the important thing is
even we had nothing
we started giving back whether it was
the first company to say we will never
test on animals and never have to this
state wow or other things we do not
shake your hand today sure you betcha
but i applaud you that's awesome it's
still going on that one the best
analytical framework
for
understanding the future is physics
i'd recommend studying
the
uh
the thinking process around physics like
not just not not the equations i mean
the equations certainly that are helpful
but the the the way of thinking in
physics is
the it's the best framework for
understanding things that are
counter-intuitive
and
you know always taking the position that
you are some degree wrong
and your goal is to be less wrong over
time
the
one of the biggest mistakes people
generally make and i'm guilty of it too
is wishful thinking
you know like you want something to be
true
even if it isn't true
and so you ignore the things that
uh you ignore the real truth because of
what you want to be true
this is a very difficult trap to avoid
and like i said certainly one that i
find myself in
having problems with
but if you just take that approach of
you're always to some degree wrong and
your goal is to be less wrong
and and solicit critical feedback
particularly from friends
like friends particularly friends if
somebody loves you
they want the best for you they don't
want to tell you the bad things you have
a lot of smart people
but you say there's a difference between
smart and wise
tell us about that yeah
the difference between smart people know
what they want
and why people know what they don't want
so i have a lot of smart people it's
difficult to deal with smart people
very difficult it's easy to deal with
stupid people you know they follow they
go to toilet they go to the restaurant
together but smart people is all
different but what we need a company is
not is not a farm my company is a zoo
we have all kinds of
animals
people talk people never talk people
work hard people never work i mean these
are
this is this is amazing ecosystem of the
company that make the company very very
powerful and colorful i feel happy that
and a leader is not the proof you are
smarter than the others
a leader's job
is to making sure everybody giving their
smart ideas out
you listen to them
and sometimes you make a stupid decision
because you have to balance
have to believe in the future it's not
smart to people win
it's the wise people
win
and for the future
so
this is what i believe we need more wise
people
our leaders smart
machine will be always smarter than you
are
but machine can never be wiser
smart people using brain
wise people using heart
machines don't have heart machines only
have chips
so this is what i think
human beings should always learn
to be wise
to say no to know what you don't want i
went through some tough times
after after i left the oprah show i made
a conscious decision
that i did not want to be sitting on tv
with the oprah show and y'all saying she
should have left that show
that show was really good two years ago
i made a conscious decision decision
that when i felt i had said all that i
could say
and the audience had heard it
that i would move on and that i would
not spend my life regretting or trying
to hold on to what used to be or hold on
to what i had so i dreamed this dream
of starting a network
and in the beginning it was it was a
struggle
it was a struggle because
i didn't honestly the goodness i did not
know what i was doing
i was trying to figure it out i was
trying to figure it out i thought that
the oprah show audience would follow us
to own then i realized y'all didn't have
cable
and if you had cable you did not have
the own package
[Applause]
so
so it took me a minute
and unlike most people who you get to
have your mistakes in private some don't
go right in your life you get to
sulk about it in private if i make a
mistake it's on the cnn crawl
or the cnn news so when i was in the
climb and there were so many wonderful
owners i see churro action jackson here
there were so many wonderful owners
people who said oh we're gonna stand
with you we're gonna stand by you thank
you roland martin there were so many
people who said listen we believe that
this can happen
so i dreamed the dream
along with tyler perry who was my friend
who came to me and said tyler
tyler said i'm going to help you out
because tyler can go home and write a
script and direct it produce it and
shoot it
and do it for less money than anybody in
hollywood so we started with the
foundation of having have not
[Applause]
if loving you is wrong
love thy neighbor
mama hattie
and then i started to dream another
dream about
scripted television because in the
beginning i was told you couldn't do it
he couldn't do it didn't have enough
money to do it
and
i dreamed the dream
i read proverbs 11 28 that says those
who trust in their riches will fall but
the righteous will rise and thrive like
a green leaf i haven't had any
existential crisis
knock on wood i find i don't want to
jinx anything
but we've had a lot of
kind of
dramatic events i remember um
early on
we only had 125 employees
when barnes and noble who the big united
states bookseller
opened their online website to compete
against us barnes noble.com we'd had
about a two-year window we opened in 95
they opened in 97
and at that time all of the headlines
and the funniest were about how we were
about to be destroyed by this much
larger company we had 125 employees
and
60 million dollars a year in annual
sales 60 million with an m
and that uh and barnes noble at the time
had 30 000 employees
and about 3 billion dollars in sales
so they were giant we were tiny
and we had limited resources and the the
headlines were very negative about
amazon and the one that's most minimal
or memorable was just amazon.toast
and um
and so i called an all hands meeting
which was not hard to do with just 125
people and we got in a room and because
it was so um scary for all of us
this idea that now we finally had a big
competitor that literally
everybody's parents were calling and
saying you know are you okay
it's usually the moms
calling and asking their children are
you going to be okay so and i said look
you know it it's okay to be afraid um
but don't be afraid of our competitors
because they're never going to send us
any money be afraid of our customers and
if we just stay focused on them in in in
in instead of
obsessing over this big competitor that
we just got
that we'll be fine you talked about
companies having a unique advantage can
you speak more on that for me please
sure i mean
what is it that that
a customer can get from you that they
can't get from anybody else and you have
to be very careful with that too when i
just talked about lying to yourself as
an entrepreneur
because often we'll say well it's just
like uber but it has pink cars uber
doesn't have pink cars
that that's a difference without a
distinction right
lots of times people get confused
between what's a product and what's a
feature pink uber cars
that's a feature that's not a unique
product
excuse me so you have to know what it is
that you do
that is so unique people's the people
your potential customers say whoa
i did not know that as opposed to well
let me go tell uber that they should
probably add pink cars
because whenever you're competing with
them you know all of you are going to
compete with amazon at some point
if you're not already just the reality
and so you've got to understand when
amazon starts looking at my customer
base what is it that i can convey to
them that makes me unique and that's
that's what i meant by unique difference
i've seen people rip you apart
on both sides
for both
how
how does that
what what what
how does that drive you does that drive
you at all does that does that on
political correctness of having to
conform and being what everybody says
you're supposed to be
does that
drive you at all
well it's it's uh you try you try to you
try to ignore it to some extent you know
you try um
not to um
but you don't you know you don't try to
um you don't try to put yourself into
any of these um very uncomfortable
straight jackets and you know you don't
want um and i think that's
that's what's so uh
pernicious about all the identity
politics that uh that um you know we we
all have to be
in in this category we're all the same i
think people are all different we're all
you know we're all we're all you know
i'm somewhat idiosyncratic but i think
all of us are all of us are
idiosyncratic in different ways and i
think i think this is a this is
something that um most people experience
that they're being put into boxes way
more than they're comfortable you know
there's this interview question i always
like asking people tell me something
that's true that very few people agree
with you on
and
it's a very hard question to answer
um and it's it's not because people
don't have answers they actually have
lots of answers to it it's because
they're uncomfortable answering it in
the context of an interview because um
you know if it has the answer has to be
something the person asking you won't
agree and we're always nervous about
doing that we always want to fit in and
this uh this this pressure to fit in is
uh
is is really powerful i had a guy the
other day asked me for some advice okay
you know these people that ask for
advice i know you know
you give it to them and then they they
don't do it yeah
he knew it was true it hit him
he's like i know that's right and then
he went and did something different this
is a big mistake people make man things
the best things that have happened to me
did not require
any more thought
the best decisions i've made in my life
were instant
so like my wife and i like when i've
decided to buy something i go buy it i
don't check with her because that adds
thought it adds time
and and
this is another bad piece of advice i
was given like take time
think about it don't move too fast take
baby steps
uh you don't know nobody on this planet
ever took baby steps
they went fast
and and the faster you can go you know
my plane is safest when it's up in the
air
when it's landing slowing down it's in
trouble when it's taken off it's it's at
risk that's interesting at flight at
full speed it's almost the same that
thing wants to fly
you know and and people people are being
conditioned to slow down think about it
take your time take a drug i was put on
lithium when i was 20 29 years old
because the the psychologist thought i
needed to slow down
she was scared of speed
i wasn't and at that time were you doing
well financially
i was doing great but everybody was
saying hey you're doing too much of this
and you're doing too much of that and
you're going to burn and you're going to
do this and people were worried about me
around me they were going slow i was
vibrating faster than they were
but a hummingbird vibrates bumblebees
vibrate right they do things that are
impossible so
you don't want to slow down
and and you want to move with speed and
certainty that means people need to know
what they're doing
if i know what i'm doing that's why
confident people tiger won today talking
one today he's been fighting man been
efforting ten years he hadn't had a win
he won today that guy moves with speed
and certainty
you know winners move with speed and
certainty because they practice they
train they educate i like the people who
never give up
and i've been proved this for so many
years i've seen so many great leaders in
the world in many many fields
those people are always optimistic they
don't complain
ah you know because of this because that
now
they think they completely complain uh
i was not that smart i did not think
about that clearly so i have to need to
change
so if you find a people who always
complain the others because he needs
success don't hire him don't work him
with him and the way i tend to view
problems is from a from a physics
standpoint and i think i think physics
is a good analytical framework um
and one of the key things in in physics
is to reason from first principles
this is contrary to the way most human
reasoning takes place which is by
analogy
um
reasoning from first principles just
means that you you figure out what are
the fundamental
what are the fundamental truths or or
things that are pretty people are pretty
sure are fundamental truths and and can
you build up to a conclusion from that
uh you know perform those principles and
um
and then certainly if you come up with
some idea and it appears to violate one
of those
fundamental truths then you're probably
wrong um
or you should get a really big prize or
something like that
um
so
this may seem like i don't know it may
seem sort of obvious when it's explained
but it's actually not what people do
reasoning my analogies is helpful
because it's a shortcut yeah
and it's and it's mostly correct but but
it tends to be most incorrect when
you're dealing with new things
because it's hard to analyze to
something really new i'm a student of
observation i i observe things i
remember being being selling cars saying
this is stupid
first i learned how to do it right
customer the 12 steps right and then i'm
like if i do 12 steps with everybody i
can't get to 30 units a month
and then i'm like i started skipping
steps right
uh i mean because i wanted i wanted
those 10 car car weeks
and the only way to do that was walk out
there and just start offering people
what they had what they what they were
going to ask me for anyway right can i
get you a price a payment a down payment
a monthly bank can i get you everything
you need right i knew that it was just a
matter of about 30 seconds they were
gonna ask for it all no doubt so i just
basically intercepted the customer sped
up the processes and and then i'm like
man i started hitting 30 36 units 31
units in 14 days i'm like this is the
way to do it and then when i lost my job
because the dealer wasn't big enough
didn't think big enough himself didn't
10x
when i left him i didn't have any place
to go
in his company or his organization i
couldn't be a star there
i went out and started teaching it big
believers in in united way and and what
goes on there and that's more at a
business level we sort of think every
business ought to do that as a basic
thing because social services
we think have a pro deserve particular
priority in terms of drawing employees
in to
to help help the community and there's
ways to take those fundraising things
within a company and have contests and
comparisons and great stories get the
word out make it fun make it easy you
know it's just a piece of email the
easiest thing to do is click and say you
want to give your fair share and then we
send you no more email uh so we've
made it the easiest thing to do is is
is
participate in terms of individuals it's
quite different
you know you can take
and give to groups like united way who
are really thinking about everything in
the community or you can find things and
most people mix this you can find things
that you're particularly interested in
that you know about that relative
benefited from or that you want to go
and volunteer
in
uh you know microsoft does the thing now
for every hour that somebody volunteers
we actually
uh make a grant to that organization
because that says that there they care
about it and uh they think it's it's
doing very good work
now for individuals at some levels
probably most you're giving is going to
be
in the community where you know what's
going on i'm a big believer that that
the some of the greatest inequities are
on a global basis
and so
one of the things our foundation tries
to get out is the names of a number of
organizations like save the children or
global fund or vaccine fund that we know
are taking dollars in a very efficient
way and saving lives and improving
conditions and you know i would hope
that as people
are able to be fairly generous that this
international component that it be part
of of what they're doing
obviously if you get up to enough scale
then you can
take on big projects and i will get a
chance with some of my extra time to go
out and and share with people who are
lucky enough to have wealth and just
tell them how much fun i'm having and
that can have impact and hopefully
encourage it i i think when warren
buffett gave his gift it sent a message
to people that wow
uh and we got we
this is the the right thing to do and
you know he he doesn't like to waste
money uh so you know a sense that there
are causes out there now i'm going
through and teaching myself neural
networks and you know doing the same
thing with machine learning and gans and
this and that because
ai
is going to have more of an impact than
the internet did ai plus new types of
chipsets plus 5g is going to change
things far more than we've ever seen
anything change and understanding where
and how to apply it is going to be
critical but just as important knowing
how to sep
segregate and separate the
yeah right is as important because every
email y'all are about to send me
is going to say i have this ai solution
and we're using algorithms
yeah of course you are right and then
what what really makes you different
what really sets you apart but if i
didn't do that work if i didn't sit down
and do the aws machine learning
tutorials if i didn't go on youtube and
take you know the nyu introduction to
neural networks or whatever i'm not
going to know it i'm not going to be
able to apply it and i'm not going to be
able to be first and that's fun that's
fun knowing i get to kick the ass to
some 22 year old nyu graduate that's
awesome in the past you invested in
china south korea and israel
and recently you partnered with 3g
capital and joshua lemon
from brazil over for the heinz deal
does this mean are you tempted to
venture into the brazil market next
i didn't get the question question you
did the hinds deal the question is are
you gonna invest in brazil next oh uh i
don't know where i'm gonna invest next
that's what that's what makes my job
interesting i mean uh i'm i'm i'm not
kidding i mean if you went out and
played golf
and every drive went in the hole you'd
give up the game wouldn't be interesting
i mean
what's interesting is when you get in
the rough and you have to come out and a
few things like that so i
i love the fact that i don't know what
i'm going to do next you mentioned the
israel investment
in 2006 in the fall
i got a letter from a fellow
and i never heard of him
and i never heard of the company he was
talking about but he said my name is
eton wardheimer
and i want to tell you a little about my
company ishkar the letter was a page and
a half long and he said
if he sold the company the family sold
the company the only company they wanted
to sell it to was berkshire hathaway and
if i was interested they'd be glad to
come over from israel and explain it to
me and it was a it just jumped off the
page that this was an interesting idea
so i emailed them and they came over
very shortly and
and we bought the business we we handed
them four billion dollars for 80 of a
company where i never seen it or
anything aton kept saying you got to
come over to israel and see the plants
and everything you won't believe how
wonderful they are and i said hey tom
i don't go to council bluffs iowa you
know i mean
i am doing fine in omaha and
uh he said no you know you got to see it
i said no no i don't i i said we can
make a deal without seeing it he said
well if you buy if you buy the company
will you come and see it i said if we
buy the company i'll come so we bought
the company and i went over there and
it's true i've never seen plants like
this it was the greatest operation i've
ever seen and etan said to me he said
you know that's why i want you to come
over to see these things i said listen
if i'd come and see them i'd have paid
more money so
so it uh
we
we have a wonderful partnership with the
people in israel but i don't know
tomorrow
uh our partnership with the people in
brazil with george apollo lemon and his
associates they are sensational people i
i got to know george apollo when i was
on the port of gillette with him and the
opportunity to buy into a wonderful
business like heinz
and to be partners and they do
they'll do all the heavy lifting they
run the place uh with georgie pollon
associates i mean it's just
it's a it's a great opportunity for us
and i don't know what the opportunity
will be tomorrow with george apollo is
last december
uh
i was going out to boulder colorado
where he had a group that met and he
said i think i've got an idea might
interest you when i get out there and so
i went out there and and uh and as we
came back on the plane he explained what
he was thinking about in terms of heinz
and i said
count me in and
uh and i will tell you one other thing
which is quite impressive about him
after i said that and went a little a
little further on the thing he sent me a
one-page
governance description of how it would
work between the two of us and he sent
me a very brief description of
what he thought would be a fair deal for
both of us i didn't have to change a
word i mean those are the kind of people
you liked it we haven't i've been asked
for years
um
we ever opened physical stores literally
20 years have been asked the question i
always say yes but only when we have
a differentiated
differentiated offering something that's
not me too
because that space physical storage is
so well served if we offer a me to
product offering it's not gonna work
we're and it's also just we're not very
good at that most of the whenever we've
tried
dabbling in something that's a me too
service we tend to get
beaten it doesn't work we're we're our
culture is much better at pioneering and
inventing and so we have to have
something that's different and that's
what amazon go is it's completely
different the amazon bookstore
completely different and we have ideas
about how to merge prime and whole foods
to make that those are still rolling out
you haven't seen them yet but to make to
use amazon prime to make whole foods a
very differentiated experience and so
what we're going to be able to do is
take some of our resources some of our
technical technological know-how and and
expand the whole foods mission
they have a great mission which is to
bring nourishing food to everybody
organic nourishing food to everybody
and
but you know we have a lot to bring to
that table in terms of resources but
also in terms of operational excellence
and in terms of technology know-how you
came from very modest circumstances you
didn't come from a wealthy family well
modest is not the word well i was trying
to be polite i was i was actually
poor and i you know a lot of the girls
at my school actually all the girls from
my school are poor and i was saying to
them just recently i was just in south
africa for graduation you know you all
are comf come from the same
circumstances you were poor and one of
the girls raised their hand and said i
don't like using that word i go well if
you're not poor then you should excuse
yourself because that's why i'm paying
for you because you're in my school so
if you're not but you don't like the
choice of the word so i don't i don't
have a problem with the word
i don't have any shame about it i think
you know probably earlier in my life or
career the word would have bothered me
but it truly it was it was i was poor no
running water david or electricity
living with an outhouse
okay that's poor we have a culture
that's very focused on um being very
focused on what we're building
so focus is a really important part of
it but it wasn't at google for a long
time now it seems to be in vogue so they
may be saying you know this the focus is
better but so
but at the same time we want to make
sure that everyone can come and and add
their ideas i mean some of the best
ideas throughout the the company's
evolution
they have just been from just places all
throughout the company whether it's an
engineer or you know someone on the the
customer support team or just different
uh just different areas around the
company so
we've always had these hackathons right
that are basically time that we allocate
that the only rules that you don't work
on what you work on the rest of the time
and it's basically an incubator for
people to prototype different ideas much
in the spirit of how facebook got
founded originally um the idea that you
can build anything good in a day or a
couple of days right and get a version
of that running
um so you get it running you then test
it internally yeah and then we can see
and that that helps us shape the road
map and what we want to do in the future
but
we also have a culture where we want to
stay very focused and um we don't want
to run with a lot of projects that we
don't expect to launch right so
so we want to get a lot of ideas help
have those ideas shape where we want to
go and then execute in a very focused
way on the stuff that we're going to do
but i mean
our culture i mean we have a few values
that are really important to us i think
when dreams start to brew in us or when
there's like a seed planted in us where
we have this dream it kind of started
that way where i was like like it was
like a little inkling like wait a minute
if i if i could figure out how to
launch how to create a product that
works for me i better help a lot of
other people and then i would kind of
like silence that dream and i would my
head would take over oh jamie you have
no connections you have barely any money
you don't know anything about the beauty
industry and you're you're in your dream
job right now it's really important to
differentiate yourself i say that more
than anything you've got to get to the
point and you've got to give the what's
in it for them very concisely and very
quickly so with with differentiating
yourself i'll use an example i always
say you've got to differentiate you've
got to tell the person or the world why
you're unique and why you're different
very clearly and concisely then you have
to let them know why you're unique and
different in comparison to other options
they may have and then you need to let
them know why that matters to them
so
i'll use my own journey and just give
you the example i also say it's really
important to sell the problem you're
solving not just the product
so i'll take my spanx so when i first
invented spanx if i were to plug in this
equation and how important it was the
first thing i said to the buyer or
anybody if i was in the media if i got a
chance to be on the news i would say
do you have you know you know how women
have things hanging in their closet that
we have no idea what to wear under
and then they would nod and so i
immediately started with the problem
creating the problem that i'm now about
to solve then i would say and then you
know how our underground options they're
not that great you have regular
underwear that leaves a panty line that
you can see or these very thick heavy
duty girdles that are too thick under
your beautiful clothes or your nice
slacks and leave lines on your legs
okay then i've just given them the
options that are dysfunctional and then
i tell them well i've just invented this
product and look what it does it meets
in the middle of the options that are
out there and here's why it's going to
be important to you here's why it's
going to matter you're going to be able
to wear white you're going to be able to
wear cream you're finally going to be
able to wear all the fabrics in your
closet that you don't wear anymore and
you're going to you're going to look
amazing you're going to have no lines so
then i would give the what's in it for
them but that's just a quick example and
i would always i like to start with the
problem that i'm solving have them just
sort of invest in it with you
and then um why the other options aren't
so great people need to know from you
you're the only one that can do it why
you're their best choice if success is
contingent on a good plan excellent edu
you know education and execution in a
driven mindset
what do you think
makes businesses fall apart um when all
of these factors have been met and con
sorry go ahead some businesses are just
tough i mean a significant percentage
you know the restaurants that that open
up this year are going to fail i mean
there are a lot of a lot of tough
businesses uh i've always said if you
want to be regarded as a great business
person find a great business
and
there's a huge difference i mean it does
make a difference i
use this analogy when
when i got out of columbia one of my
best friends was a terrific talent
and
uh he went to work in the steel business
and he did okay
but it was the wrong business to be in
it's very important to get on the right
train i mean you want to you want to get
on a train that's going to go 90 miles
an hour and not one that's going to go
30 miles an hour and you're going to try
to figure out how to you know push it
along a little faster so it really does
make a huge difference uh and and
there are some businesses that are
inherently uh there's far more
opportunity and than others so you want
to give a lot of thought to what train
you're getting on and
uh i owned a half interest when i was i
don't know 21 or 22 in a service station
uh a sinclair service station with a pal
of mine in the national guard it was a
lousy business you know we had a guy
right next to us he kept selling more
gallons of gas that we did he would cut
our prices and everything i mean i i
don't i don't care if you know if you're
a combination of steve jobs and larry
ellison and everyone else you're not
going to succeed if you've got a guy
selling gas below cost next year so you
know what it's important to get on the
right train i have had before
co-partners
in some businesses i've tried and not as
good as my partner paul mitchell but in
other businesses and they didn't turn
out to be what i thought they would be
so if you have a partner one you've got
to be friendly to one another you also
have to have your boundaries where okay
i live my life you live your life we
can't live it all together we're
together we have a certain goal now if
you do have i call it a challenge
opposed to a problem
the best way to address it is not do it
for example aggressively
don't attack on it instead it's much
easier to say
well you know liz uh you're you're a
wonderful person we've done some really
great business together but with all due
respect when i came in here i had a
great idea wanted to tell you and you
kept on cutting me off and it made me
feel bad liz you know as well it just
made me feel bad and i know you'd like
to hear it i just wanted to share that
with you you share your feelings with
the person if they have an idea you
don't think it's any good you could say
you know that's that that's a great idea
i could appreciate where you're coming
from always validate the person however
can we look at this a little differently
maybe we can enhance it and build upon
it and you come in with your two cents
always respect the other person one of
the things when i really sit and think
why why am i comfortable taking risks
what is it yeah um where i come from i
was really lucky when i was growing up
my dad used to actually encourage my
brother and me to fail
and so i would come home and sit at the
dinner table and he would say sarah what
did you fail at this week
and if i didn't have something he would
actually be disappointed and i can
vividly remember coming home and saying
dad dad i tried out for this and i was
horrible and he would high-five me
and what i i didn't realize it's so
awesome i didn't realize it at the time
but it was he was teaching us that
failure is is not trying versus the
outcome and so with spanx and everyone's
saying it was such a bad idea initially
and you know i feel like i feel much
freer to be willing to
you know fail in the traditional sense
because i'm not focused on the out end
result and the more it's like working a
muscle the more you're willing to risk
something and maybe fail you realize
there's always a really awesome hidden
gift in it
it's either you meet someone new that
brings you to a different place in your
life or you learn something new or
and and so i always was really excited
by what how my life grew by every risk i
took education
is essentially a social construct
it's not that the universities have
secret knowledge that only they have
available uh
you know i took
these numbers won't make any sense
anymore but the hardest freshman math
class was called math 55
uh
i assume it's not called that anymore uh
but it was it was a group of
uh as a group of 80 people whose
personal positioning was they were the
best person at math that they had ever
met so there were 79 frauds uh
one
person who really was the the best at
math i ended up the guy who came in
first in the class is a lawyer in new
york now uh the guy who came in second
is a professor of chaos theory of uh
princeton and then i came in third
so i knew okay math geez
that's interesting anyway
i didn't take physics
55
but i read the feynman book and so
if you're motivated
seriously you don't have to take a
course the feynman book if you're
hardcore just read the finding book do
the problems you want to learn to do
software read the art of computer
programming good luck doing the problems
but uh you know anyone that's rated 30
or harder is like super hard to do
and so
a mooc in a sense
doesn't change what counts
uh you know it's always been in the
textbook but the percentage of students
who just buy textbooks and and read them
and know the subject is vanishingly
small you kind of have to have this
thing where a bunch of kids all come at
the same time uh
and you know if you don't study you're
going to get a bad grade and your
parents may not like that
you have to create all these social
things
in order for people to get into this
mode of hyper concentrating
and actually understanding why should i
concentrate you know if i'm a high
school student they put x's and y's up
on the board
how does that relate to my life now if
you understood that being good at math
lets you get a good job travel the world
you might say okay it does relate to me
but that's a very
indirect thing and the kind of
discipline
to care about that
uh to concentrate that's what's missing
and so moocs to the degree that it's
easier to take a mooc than it is to read
a textbook yeah that's nice it's a
little bit interactive there's a video
that's partly why i like the learning
company like all their economics this
guy named timothy taylor who has five
courses on economics i super recommend
and you learn to like him and his way of
explaining things so a mooc is a
slightly more digestible form
of learning but it doesn't take
particularly for somebody at a young age
it in no way changes this question of
why should people
uh engage in that learning and how do
you create the environment and the sense
of achievement and the sense of
capability
that sitting in there and you know
looking at x's and y's and manipulating
them
seems like a smart thing to do
[Music]
if you want even more lessons from
billionaire entrepreneurs check out the
video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there you should just be
yourself
right i mean i take pride in the fact
that i didn't give what anybody thought
or said i was just going to be myself i
find if i don't get enough sleep then
i'm i'm quite grumpy
[Music]